you knew lambeth at the time I mean
they're to central allegations here that
there was sex abuse going on on council
property and that this was somehow
linked to boot bullet full-size death
that would you make of those two central
allegations both true and this was a
cesspit of corruption did five years
before Bullock Forsythe was murdered I
stumbled across clear evidence of a
paedophile ring and abuse going on using
boys from lambeth children's homes which
I gave to the police and that police
investigation to courtly two police
officers investigating was stopped by
people on high within the police the
same thing happened again in the mid
nineties and what about the connection
to mr. Forsythe there or without
question he had come across the video
eng of child abuse in a Lambeth
children's home he was clearly going to
be talking about that and they put the
evidence together and he was murdered
and that's the little ambiguity about
that from the evidence that I've seen I
knew it uses an MP I mean you've seen
evidence this is not just your belief I
mean you use I've seen I've seen I've
seen the evidence and I was aware from
the things that I saw and I stumbled
across out looking at corruption more
widely had a huge corruption
investigation laws of people were sacked
because of it and we stumbled across
this as part of the investigation real
did stumble across E and it was clear
that there was significant child abuse
going on it was organized there are a
lot of violence involved and there's
people out there who know there's people
out there who know about the cover-up
one person gained me last week with so
many clear evidence about the cover-up
that ensued in the 90s that are more
people out there who know part of this
story and they ought to be speaking to
the police Jim gamble does this this is
a very serious allegation obviously
corruption child abuse murder and
coverup does this sound credible to you
well it sounds credible the unfortunate
thing is that you know we've heard it
before I mean if you just simply
ticker a moment to pause and reflect
Jimmy Savile Operation Yewtree the
allegations around dolphin square what
we know about what's happened in rather
them and know this apart from what's
going on in can kill kincora at jersey
and elsewhere you've got to wonder and
what's been going on and why it's been
allowed to go on for so long we've
really come to a moment in time when yes
reviews will be important and the
lessons learned must be applied but
there has to be robust criminal
investigations that take advantage of
any evidence that is still remaining and
and no stone can or should be left
unturned this is unusual in as much as
there's the clear suggestion that
someone who was trying to uncover it was
murdered and we know that mr. Forsythe
was killed well I mean there there's a
key issue at the end of the day there
are enough people still around and still
alive and for this investigation to have
a meaningful bite at the allegation that
this person was murdered linked and to
them about to expose this is extremely
serious and really you know words defy
me because i'm not sure what i can say
that will put this in context accept
this the time has come for us to stop
reflecting on reviews the time has come
to hold people to account and the
unfortunate thing is this Savile in the
70s what we've seen about the 1980s what
we've seen around dolphin square in the
1990s this issue and right up to did in
Rotherham a lack of leadership and a
culture of control and cover up we've
got to do something that wipes all that
away and it has to be about robust
contemporary police investigations and
that's going to mean investment in
serious resource capability where are
these items of clothing what DNA is
still available you know hire the police
answering questions about the evidence
that was supposedly handed to them in
the earlier mid 1990s there are huge
issues here that go directly to the
heart of public confidence and the
confidence of survivors in the
competence of the police service and the
institutions that are supposed to
protect them a German in this specific
case of lambeth and what's less have
gone there
link to this death what do you want to
happen and is it happening I want people
to come forward to the police there is a
very big police investigation but I know
there's a lot of people out there who've
got vital bits of information and there
are victims out there who've not been
believed in the past people need to come
forward however however small however
unsure they are if they think they've
your information there are bits that are
bits that the police need that are
absolutely vital and do you have
confidence in the police investigation I
have confidence in this police
investigation now in the past it was
blocked and it was blocked twice the
current operation Trinity I've got
confidence in the police officers there
have been suggestions with things like
the raids on the home of the former
Field Marshal Lord Bramall or pair
indeed Paul Gambaccini experience that
perhaps this investigation is going for
headlines rather than the nitty-gritty
well the police the police and people
like me kodak european parliament and
name the names the police could name the
names that the operation trinity isn't
doing that i think that's the right
approach follow the evidence and let's
nail some of these people and get them
jailed that's what I want to see and
that's the way they're dealing with it
I'm impressed by their professionalism
but there are people out there there'll
be people watching who've got vehicle
information who haven't given it to the
police it's about time they did this